at its very best social media has the
power to bring people together but it
has also made it easier to spread lies
and to attack people for who they are
and in that latter category that
includes anti-Semitism now more
prevalent by many measures and it has
been in decades it's according to the
Anti-Defamation League when synagogue in
Los Angeles is giving Jewish teenagers
now the space to talk about
anti-Semitism as a group Carter Evans
spoke with some of those teens to find
out how hatred is affecting them
personally
at show Murray Torah synagogue outside
Los Angeles what are the things that you
have had to deal with in terms of
anti-Semitism in your own lives rabbinic
intern avra melner has an honest talk
with Jewish teens who speak openly
swastikas were being spray painted in my
locker area they were saying Heil Hitler
I was just heartbroken when I heard what
Kanye said because truthfully it's not
just Kanye that's saying all of this
it's a catalyst for so much more how did
you deal with it what did you do to get
through that moment I took off like any
jewelry that indicated that I was Jewish
and I didn't deny but I kind of erased
it from like my personality publicly a
lot of the time because I was just
afraid I think what struck me about this
conversation is how easily all of you
were able to come up with multiple
instances where you were the subject of
anti-Semitism so maybe with a show of
hands how many many of you have seen
swastikas in school
so most of you okay how many of you have
been subjected to anti-semitic language
in school
the first time you realized what
anti-Semitism was the first time you
experienced it maybe saw it how old were
you I was online I think I was seven or
eight
and it was like a super popular like
game and there were these two trolls I
guess and they said hail Hitler guess
the Jews and I still remember those
exact words like so many years later
because they just kind of hit really
deep
and it was kind of like a shaping
experience for me what about social
media do you see a lot of anti-Semitic
language on social media yeah that
um that I believe is where I got my I
had my first encounterment with an
anti-semite he ended up texting me one
time in all caps of an oven
which is not the same text yeah I did
report his account but like there's no
way of knowing if anything actually
happened do you feel that it's easier
for people to be anti-semitic online
yeah it's like a blanket of protection
over them they could go online as any
other name and
like say extremely
extremist things and and then if oh no
that count gets banned I'll make another
one I think that social media and pop
culture has had some positive effects on
marginalized communities but we've also
just seen the amplification of
stereotypes and harmful conspiracies
when someone like Kanye West
amplifies
those types of messages with his
platform does that give those words more
power yeah yeah unfortunately it does
because if he has a huge fan base his
followers on some social media account
are double the amount of Jews on in the
world which is crazy to think about I
know at least some of them might be
anti-semites and that's a problem it
goes from people you know saying he's
not really like that he's whatever going
through a tough time and then the next
second there are neo-nazis holding up
signs on the 405 freeway on an overpass
saying Kanye was right about the Jews
which brings me to another question
why should
everybody else care about anti-Semitism
it's not just Jews this can happen to
anybody anti-Semitism right now it's
talking about Jews but there are so many
ways that it could be flipped against
different minority and maybe even
sometimes majority groups any harm being
done to human beings is unacceptable and
no matter who you are it you should care
not because we're Jewish but just
because we're other humans
exactly right another awful conversation
very powerful and they're so young to
get this lesson so early it's just
another really really strong example of
how your words have a lot of power and I
like what the young man said you know
Kanye's words are a catalyst for others
right you may think differently and act
out some of the craziest things that
they've heard yeah teenagers already
have enough to deal with exactly right
yeah yeah other teenagers are acting I
mean
they don't you don't know anything right
at that age and that's not who you want
to be yeah and you need to learn
something no doubt about it